одні хитромудрим на екрані за є
зображення тварюкою в мистецтві
берлінською з цього значення майка i
love man на прес-конференції показуючи
шедевр річки і тревал і годину поважали
страшного з рідних туру пікассо мати
sata крокувала
полем бірж приколи стоїш перед шедевром
маяки тревал і годину поважали astra ченом
і пропала ми б зірки оновити жінки
ми і батюшки роботи в досить таки
доброму стані труха грязний ми про
таємні вушко джинами до зірок ніж
чуваш невинність частини у наомі кицьку
люкс кафе можете 2 тисячі тварин у
майстерності було знай дано в ні шийний
прийме її квартирі 80 і особисто вмієш
кінця мінфіну корнеліуса burrito картину
максу бетмана приборку варшаві в
пенсіонер на вірш про даташиту оптику це
і мала рацію динуша у лютому 2012 року
ришта рубає права run себе значився раз
митя tab розтрачених консерви
5 годин щоку конфіскував та 1285 полотен
без рами і сто двадцять одну картину в
рамах з і рідних роботи відомих травень
stream ag на це з них рубати наклала
єврейським раді нам їх конфіскували
нацисти
про гітлера скинь і начиніть твор і був і
за таврове не відпочинок та наративним
природа
конфісковано карти на арт-дилер і мало
prodad з-за кордону би заробляли щось
для нацистів
одним стакам геларіум бачку гур літа
частин нору між прахова потім щось їм
на парадів синів нині влада домагається
вагою в ти че і всі картини предметом
зло чину проти владності топ те чого
краще про владно ним чужого майна
і все так чинно splif термін давності у
це право я перестаю to my top tube
цій нікому сама юридично вона лежить
сенсацій призначить до завищується вигляд
критим ми відразу милий те, чим у влада
повторити руку відсоток джалла пояс на ньому
залишитися дізнавшись не майка huffman так і
проведення експертизи процес найму
поверну складні і when she do like а адже
завершення